so if life is the the best way to fight
entropy
you can imagine that life permeates
the entire universe and then the
question might change to like flavors of
ice cream what are the flavors of
complexity that this process this nature
of Life leads to and there we might have
bias about what complexity looks like
what beautiful complexity looks like
we'll look at humans that operate a
certain physical scale and uh time scale
and we think this is intelligence we
have another problem we don't know what
life is we don't know what intelligence
is and we don't know what Consciousness
is but we are trying to tackle the big
question but do you know what complexity
is also you know no I I think that we
have to be honest and as a scientist and
I'm going to step back and talk about
intelligence for me bacteria
that has survived like cyanobacteria
that has survived just like us
four billion years in one Incarnation or
another and actually they are very
similar to the one that they wear 3.5
billion years ago it has some
intelligence about its environment
so for complexity it might be
that we need to take the world literally
which is an assemblage or additional
capacity to gather collect store
information maybe this is something like
that or actually use that information to
do something with it
but I do completely agree with you when
you talk about flavor of ice cream I
think this is exactly it and
I have a basic education about what
physics is doing right now
and I'm look at quantum physics and what
it says about the universe and about the
connection about an atom here and
another hair a photon here in the Forum
there and I am starting to put Maybe
wrongfully two and two together but in
my mind
and of course it's nothing until I can
prove it but in my mind the universe is
connected everywhere in all different
places so this life connection is
something that as you said pyramid the
universe and the way to find life
might be very different than to look for
the origins of life I think it's a good
thing to go out there and look for the
original by somewhere else because it's
the manifestation of the nature of life
that's all of a sudden becomes
apparent evident to our eye but
what I think
would be our greatest achievement is
that if we can find that process of life
because at that point in my mind the
universal is sudden is going to
illuminate itself with actually
it's living Force what I can only call a
living Force to me this is what we are
looking at a universe that becomes more
and more complex with time more and more
able to gather information and
interestingly enough why
to understand itself so Sagan was right
when he was selling we are the universe
trying to understand itself and the more
we go the more the universe become alive
maybe intelligent and maybe also
conscious